Okay.
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Jess,
before Friday,
Monday morning podcast in,
ah,
just checking it on you.
I'm just checking in to see how your week's going out.
Fuck you're doing and everything and you're fucking lap.
Um,
all right,
let's get into it.
Uh,
I already recorded this podcast.
I recorded it from my movie trailer,
um,
yesterday,
but for some reason the file corrupted.
So now I have to do it again,
which is all right because I would have made a fool of myself because I thought
last night was game three of the NBA finals and game five of the Stanley Cup
final.
I'm like,
why can't those two leaks get on the same fucking page and kind of,
you know,
just pick different nights.
But evidently that's already happened.
So,
um,
I apologize to the NBA and the NFL Nhl for the podcasts that they never heard.
Um,
I actually watched game a fucking three last night
of a Toronto verse,
uh,
Golden State Warriors.
And um,
yeah,
it was great game.
It was just,
you know,
just watching Toronto,
no matter how much golden state kept coming back,
they just kept,
they couldn't cut it less than fucking 10 or nine.
They stayed out in front of them.
They hit some big shots,
they blocked a bunch of shots and all of that shit.
Um,
you know,
this is a,
and it was very easy.
Yeah.
To root for Toronto.
You know,
it was very easy to root for because they weren't cutting the Drake every five
fucking seconds.
Whatever the hell they're doing.
Like I tune,
I'm tuning in to watch the raptors first,
the warriors.
I'm not tuning in to watch Drake,
watch the raptors in the warriors.
I don't understand it.
All right.
But I've already covered that.
So anyway,
um,
congratulations to them.
Um,
I didn't see clay play.
My,
I don't know,
I don't know shit about basketball,
but it seemed like,
um,
he wasn't playing that much either.
But,
um,
we'll say,
well,
we will see what happens.
Well,
you know what?
His fucking,
you know,
it's getting like fucking becoming a trope though,
is them cutting to Toronto sports fans standing outside their fucking arena,
uh,
in,
you know,
every time I see that I'm just like,
I don't want to watch these people fucking hang their heads in misery of another
God damn loss.
It would be,
I'm still rooting for Toronto despite all that other bs that's going on out
there.
So congratulations to them.
You two victories away from your first bucket championship,
at least at basketball and hockey.
Since I've been alive,
I don't know what's been going on with your,
uh,
what do you got the Toronto or was it the argonauts?
Ah,
the rough riders.
The stampede,
the eagles number,
roads.
I don't know.
I don't know anything about the CFL.
The Eskimos.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's talk about what I really want to talk about.
Let's talk a bottle of Saint Louis blows
coming back in game four and quite frankly,
kicking the shit out of my boss,
the Bruins.
I've never seen a Bruins team get manhandled like this in my 40 years of
watching them.
And we are simply not built for the kind of hockey that Saint Louis is playing.
And neither was Saint Louis,
I'm sorry,
neither was San Jose.
And the result of that was their top three players were unable to finish the
series.
And um,
I don't know,
this is going to be weird.
I,
this is,
this is what I believe.
Okay.
This is somebody who never got beyond fucking pond hockey,
you know,
in that sport.
Even then I wasn't even good on the pond across,
over one side,
couldn't,
could stop on one side,
couldn't skate backwards.
Um,
the way Saint Louis has playing the Bruins named to wrap it up by game six or I
don't see us winning it because I don't think we're going to have enough good
players left.
MMM.
Cause they're just taken runs at everybody and they're running our goalie and
they're playing a trap defense.
So the way to beat those guys is you have to get up,
you got a score first,
which will hopefully make them take more chances.
So they're not just going to play that fucking stupid trap defense.
We've got to dump and chase,
um,
you know,
so they can protect their fucking astoundingly mediocre goaltender.
Um,
but I will say this,
I've,
I've been a fan of,
of not only sports,
but sports is history.
And this is my prediction.
If Saint Louis wins the cup,
which they could very well do.
Yeah.
Which I felt from the beginning,
which is why I never understood people gonna do it.
We're gonna fucking sweep these guys.
It's like they are big and they're fast.
Um,
I didn't realize how filthy they were though.
which is fine though cause it's fucking playoff hockey and this has always
happened.
But the problem is,
is that because of all the whiny snowflake concepts out there who kept
pressuring them to get fighting out of the game,
what I'm actually watching is a different kind of of greenery.
It's funny that the goons used,
used to fucking police.
Um,
I dunno.
And I just think the direction that this,
this game,
when we got rid of too many Sean Thorton's and too many fucking Adam McQuaids
because those are the guys that we're missing right now,
when we would easily,
easily be able to handle St Louis and we would easily beat them.
But considering what,
just sort of a speed finesse team and the way the officials I guess,
cause it's the playoffs are calling it,
which once again,
I don't really have a problem with it.
I didn't have a problem with,
I have a problem with the fact that there's no
mmm.
That there's no,
uh,
there's no fighting.
I just,
you know,
we should have a guy up go out there and go kick the fuck out of one of the
blues.
So they calm the fuck down and we just haven't,
so why would they stop?
It's been working for them.
So this is what I think if Saint Louis wins this,
then
I,
and they're not,
you know,
reprimanded for the way that they're playing.
Then that just sends the message that this is the direction to go in and what's
going to be,
I don't know.
It's fucked because the people that are gonna suffer our,
are not going to be the fucking dirt bags skating around with their fucking
sticks up crosscheck and people in the fucking teeth.
The people who are going to suffer are the stars of the leaks,
the terrorists Sankoh's they're going to pay for it.
And I,
that goes all the way back to,
I remember back in the day when I'm the Tennessee titans,
when there was still the Houston Oilers and they got Jerry Glanville,
you know,
and Jerry's big thing is any,
any football team that he coached,
you know,
he wanted to,
he wanted to wear black,
you know,
like the Falcons were like,
they were like red with gray pants and white or whatever.
And he came there and he changed the black jerseys because he wanted to be tough
or whatever.
Right.
And then when you went to,
you know,
so he did that there,
didn't win.
And then he went to fucking,
uh,
Houston and he's like,
let's change this one to black.
It's like,
Jerry,
you're already stole the fucking Raiders colors kind of once.
We can't do it with two different franchises.
So he went out and he got a black satin fucking Oilers jacket that you would
wear with like the blue,
red and white logo.
So anyway,
his team took on his personality and they started calling the astrodome the
house of pain,
meaning you were going to go in there and obviously the defense was going to
kick the shit out of you and you were just going to have a painful fucking
afternoon playing the Houston Oilers.
And they did that for,
I don't know,
five,
six,
seven Games before Warren Moon,
CFL and NFL hall of Famer had a meeting with the defense and said,
listen,
stop saying that shit.
Stop calling this place to house of pain because you know who has to answer to
that?
Me,
I do.
I have the ball,
every offensive fucking plate and I'm going to get my ass kicked for your
shit-talking.
So shut the fuck up if you want to inflict some plain just fucking flake plane.
Right?
MMM.
So anyway,
good.
And back to what the St Louis
Blues are doing.
I think that anybody watching this shit,
if they,
if Saint Louis,
when's this?
It's going to change hockey.
It's going to start going in this direction of like,
Oh okay,
this is what the fuck we need to do.
We need,
you know,
there's no more goons to really police shit or not enough of them,
so we'll just start taking runs at people.
Uh,
I dunno,
it's a very,
it's a fucking really bizarre
series.
I can't really get my head around it.
It's like we absolutely dominated them in game one and they absolutely dominated
us and game too.
And then game three,
as far as the score went,
we absolutely dominated them,
but we played 80% in our end.
And then
game for like,
when I say they dot.
Like physically dominated us.
Like I,
I honestly thought that the way the,
the fucking liberties that they were taking and the piece of shit way that they
were playing that after they scored the empty net goal and there was no chance
of us winning,
I was literally like,
well,
we should go out and just go crosscheck one of their players right in the
fucking mouth.
Which is something that I never say,
but I was so infuriated watching that happen to everybody on the Bruins.
I Dunno.
It's weird.
So this is what I,
I think we need to win game five and games six if it goes to game seven.
I just,
I,
you know,
I think we're going to be looking like San Jose where half our teams in a
fucking mash unit.
I hope I'm wrong.
Granted,
like I said,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm a stand up comedian who fucking skates at a public rink,
one way counterclockwise should go the other way.
All of a sudden I started having problems.
So,
um,
remember I said that,
that the St Louis Blues when this thing you're going to see their style of play
is going to become the prototype.
MMM.
Yeah.
And the last time that I think we saw this was the flyers when the flyers were
not the best team.
And then they went out back when you could fight and they just dropped the
gloves and just beat the shit out of people.
And they started,
they went back to back cups.
MMM.
I mean,
I don't know.
You can't really compare anybody to the flyers.
I mean,
they would just fucking animals.
They weren't even playing hockey.
But I don't hate those flyer teams.
And I don't hate what they did because what they did,
the,
the golden age of their style of play was in the 80s where you had the perfect
balance of just some of the greatest goal scores of all time and some of the
greatest fighters of all times.
So I don't get mad at it.
And also if the flyers didn't do what they did in [inaudible] 74 and 75,
Paul Newman,
one of my favorite actors of all time,
never signs on to make the movie slapshot so I don't have a problem with it and
I really don't have a problem with the Saint Louis Blues.
It's just a hard thing to watch as a Bruins fan to watch us get physically
dominated and to try to continue to play a game.
I've,
uh,
I just,
I don't know,
I think I got to get used to that,
but all of my die hard Bruin fans and back home are keep telling me like,
just,
you know,
this is like a boxing match.
We're boxing there,
brawling,
don't get drawn into it.
And I'm like,
okay,
I don't like it.
So we shall see.
But unfortunately,
um,
I mean I can't complain about working on a movie,
but I'm,
I'm working tonight so I'm actually going to miss the game,
so I'm going to have to watch some of the highlights.
But,
uh,
oh boy.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno if this has been a,
this has been a fuck.
I,
there's,
there's no way.
There's no,
nobody who's watching this series can actually say who's going to win.
It's so fucking crazy.
Um,
so here we go.
You know what would be crazy as if Saint Louis wins this and then Toronto wins
in both of them.
And um,
I guess Toronto ends a championship drought while St Louis Ends a,
uh,
you know,
wins their first Stanley Cup.
So either way,
that'll be fun as far as sports histories go.
So I mean the St Louis Blues one but suck cause my team would lose,
but you know,
what are you gonna do?
Things happen.
Okay.
You win some,
you lose some.
All right.
But having said that,
go Bruins,
which got to fucking win five and went six.
That's it.
Take before they take this sickles out in game seven,
you know,
and chop,
literally chop a Bruins head off and get called from matching penalties.
All right.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
rumor has it,
I might be off tomorrow on,
if that's true.
I'm going to try to do some standup this weekend here in New York City.
So visit your local comedy club.
Who knows?
You might see old freckles fucking come around.
Um,
you know what,
it is great though.
I told you when I go to the,
when I go to these,
um,
when I,
whenever I do these acting gigs,
how I get through it.
Yeah.
MMM.
The bus,
the weirdness of it where like as a comedian,
if somebody tells me to do 20 minutes,
I'd do 20 minutes and it takes 20 minutes.
As an actor,
if I'm in something that's going to be 20 minutes,
six,
it's going to take like a month,
three weeks or whatever the shoot it.
Um,
I just,
when I go down,
when I go on set,
am I speaking?
That's a,
that's a good one right now on set,
on set.
You want to jump on the podcast at all?
I know you're busy.
Um,
what I do is I just,
uh,
I don't bring a Wa I don't bring a watch.
I don't bring a,
uh,
I don't bring a phone.
I have no fucking idea.
Like what time it is or anything.
And,
um,
I'm able to just sort of fucking plow through it.
But today when I go down there,
it's like a,
the Bruins games on.
So I don't know what I'm going to do.
You know,
I'm still not going to bring one,
cause I'm not going to see the fucking game anyways.
Do I need to get all my texts and my Massachusetts friends?
Oh,
what the fuck?
Yes.
Here we go,
dude.
That's bullshit.
And then I don't even know what's going on that's going to drive me up the
fucking wall.
So,
uh,
but what is cool about not bringing my phone is just not being on the phone.
And uh,
yesterday we had a long day.
We had,
we had a scene at a dinner table and uh,
anytime you see a scene at a dinner table in a movie,
uh,
I'm telling you it takes all day because there's just so many angles they have
to get in all that.
So it took a long time to shoot.
So in a good way,
I wasn't on my phone at all for like the whole day.
And I'll tell you what's hilarious.
If you don't text people,
nobody really texts you.
And I came out and I had like I think 10 text messages and I was able to handle
all of them
with either Lolz or write some business thing back in like fucking eight minutes
and I was done.
Um,
so I kind of learned something that I'm not going to apply,
but I would love to apply that in my everyday life.
And speaking of my everyday life,
here's my every day love
making her triumphant return her triumphant return.
Ever since you've been a mom,
you know,
we've just been,
we've been two ships passing in the night.
Yeah,
exactly.
So how you been,
what have you been up to?
I think good is Nia,
right?
Yeah.
Bill William,
William,
William.
I've been great.
William,
this is you guys being here though is making my,
my date,
uh,
my,
my workout in and I said Nice and easy.
You guys should do that all the time.
Like if I get stand up gigs and like Dayton on the quad cities,
you know,
we've talked about this.
Yeah,
I know you support me in the fun city.
Just not a curiosity.
If we,
if this thing was two months in Jacksonville,
Florida,
would you be here Jackson?
No.
Jacksonville.
You know what?
Maybe because I have a friend out there.
That's what I thought.
Nothing about me.
Why are you so mean?
But I would definitely,
we would definitely come out for like three weeks.
Oh,
all right.
Pay.
Did you see in Boston they're going to have a straight pride March?
Yes.
I saw that.
Fucking ridiculous.
Of course.
Boston of course.
I fucking course like what is the point?
What is the point of that?
I don't know.
This is my,
this is my thing.
Are they trolling?
Is it,
that's my thing.
My thing is is if they're doing it because it's all going to be like to just
guys,
right?
It's all going to be like white guys out there being like,
what about US law?
I think what the,
they're also petitioning that
the Lgbtq Xyz,
whatever the fuck it is that they add an s to it for straight.
No.
Yeah,
that must factual show.
I'm waiting for that.
So what I,
I'm waiting
them to be like this was a social experiment to see how blah,
blah blah,
which would be really fucking stupid.
Cause what do you need a social experiment in this to be,
they're just doing it to be like,
honestly,
when stuff like this happens,
you have to ignore it.
But it's just impossible.
Media will always pick it up and they know that.
But you got to ignore that shit.
It's like it's nothing.
It's not,
it's not even worth getting upset over.
Although I understand why some people might,
you'll get a little heat now.
You're a little heated,
so fucking stupid.
Why don't you take your own advice?
It's just fucking stupid.
Why don't you just take your own advice?
I mean I am,
but I mean I,
I had a buddy of mine text me today about it.
I am so busted me,
text me today.
He goes,
dude,
it's just a real fucking day.
He texted me.
Cause if so I'm going,
yeah.
Any texts me this fucking thing where with some flag for people who are asexual
or don't feel feelings about people,
but sometimes do and bubble and Ron Lewis,
you know,
and he's just sitting there.
I was just,
I was laughing because you know,
I've been on this booby thing so I don't fucking look at my phone.
So it's fun.
You get disconnected that quickly from everybody else.
Yeah.
Like when you're in and I'm looking at my phone,
then I'm running around to acting like the sky is falling,
but when you don't look at your phone literally for fucking 12 hours,
you're coming out like I'm on Staten Island.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Fucking weather.
And that we were sitting on the stairs in between takes and I was saying to one
of the other actors that go,
this minds me when I was a kid and she was mean like,
yeah,
I know,
right?
Yeah.
You just come out here.
You just sit down on a perfect summer day and people would come out,
you talk,
and then we kids playing in the street and just hanging out.
You didn't realize you had your whole life ahead of you,
how awesome it was.
And then the second I pick up my phone and shit,
don't have your say this,
what the fuck
it is?
Isn't there flag like black and white.
So it's that.
That seems very sort of like symbolic good black and white.
It's like straight or not.
Whereas you know they're,
they're flagged.
The LGBTQ is like the rainbow,
all inclusive.
Like however you're feeling,
doesn't it?
I thought that was more of a fashion thing.
It's not like I'm going to need more colors than that,
honey.
No,
I think it's symbolic of,
you know what?
And I don't even know.
So I might be talking out of my ass,
but I just felt like I saw that black and white one.
I was like,
oh,
I get it.
It's very black and white over over here and straight Advil.
Yeah,
come on.
There we go.
Yeah.
Images,
heterosexual flags.
Oh your first thing that comes up.
Somebody said the things to just,
oh,
of course.
It's on some Janky ass fucking website.
That's the one put together like black,
five minutes,
a white stripe flag.
Oh my God.
I have seen pose for sexuals.
I believe the design was six for dental stripe.
Northwestern.
What
obvious references to the rainbow flag essentially moved of its color.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Oh wait.
Somebody wrote that?
February,
2001 yeah.
Look at this fucking,
you know,
clip art fucking website.
Well,
that's just one of those ones where the,
what did they talk where people just talking to each other.
Oh,
like a threat or something?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Wow.
US straight sparking plans that march into controversy.
Super Happy,
Fun America,
which has applied to the city.
Whatever I don't need.
I'm going to take my own advice and I don't even want to give this any air time.
Boston planning a straight pride.
Yeah.
Boston fucking but,
oh wait,
wait,
wait.
Okay.
Read this headline.
It's LG.
Wait,
wait.
Put the,
it's LGBT pride month,
but three guys in Boston.
When a permit for a straight pride parade.
I know it's not a parade.
Okay.
Three people is not afraid.
[inaudible] we get that right.
You're dumb fucks like mine,
so everybody just relax.
Ridiculous.
Nobody's showing up to that pride model.
Kicks off of Boston on Tuesday with a lights event,
a paint night,
a preparation for a possible and preparation for possible straight pride parade
this summer.
Well,
why can't I marched down the street?
Let me tell you,
if your boyfriend or husband is participating in this March,
like you really need to reconsider your relationship.
I'll just tell you what I love about you.
You know what I love about you,
we consider is you're giving him your,
you're giving the perfect advice while taking the bait all at the same time.
I know he's just,
he just wrote me into it.
There's only gonna be three fucking people there.
You're getting worked up over three people.
Yeah.
Why do you know what?
I'm more worked up over the fact that this is like news.
What's going to happen next,
Nia?
Are they going to cancel the reboot of will and grace?
Three people are going to have a parade.
I mean,
why is everybody to the event to celebrate the heterosexual reality and one of
the nation's most gay friendly cities?
I didn't know that.
Look at us.
I mean go Boston.
Wait ways.
Matthew Pope,
funny,
fun at identity politics or the political left.
Yeah,
he's just making fun of him.
Hi Charlie.
He goes,
he's also organize free speech,
quote unquote rallies in gun rights administration.
Oh,
so this is a fucking white supremacists again,
it free.
What did you just do?
What did you just do there?
You don't know this guy.
Three straight guys.
I guarantee you they're fucking white.
They're going to do a thing to poke fun at identity politics and he wanted to
eat or you sound like a redneck right now.
Free speech and a gun rights demonstration.
Sound like a redneck right now.
Two together.
You suck is behind that.
You sound like a redneck on his front porch right now.
If I was a redneck,
I'd
wait.
Why can't I be,
you know,
missing.
My point is you don't know this guy.
No,
I do and is on,
I'm seeing in this article that was my point.
Yes,
this is what people do,
this,
this and this are also open minded like oh I get it.
C'Mon man.
Like this is what people do man on the right and the left.
You're both like sitting here and making assumptions.
Like you know that there is such that's such bullshit.
Right?
And there's wrong and there are people who are on the wrong side of things and
there are people who are at least trying to be on the right side of the bank and
making people feel comfortable and making people feel included.
Like what do you fucking care of?
Gay people have like a parade.
Why does that mean that you all,
you now have to have a parade to like poke fun at identity politics?
Like what the fuck does it even have to deal with you?
We'll be right back with Nia takes the bait after these messages.
Care.
If it's considered taking the bait,
I'm standing up for what's right.
Like who the fuck?
Like why?
Why does it matter to you that people have a parade?
It has nothing to do with you.
Leave it alone.
You're just you gotta.
You just have to now have your own praying.
I'm straight.
It's like you're being an asshole.
That's what it is.
You're being an asshole.
You're not standing up for anything that's different.
Not Making a point.
Different things,
hating people.
No,
it is.
It's a very fine line.
It's a very,
but this dude is trying to,
was trying to organize a free speech rally and a gun rights administration.
First of all,
there's a free speech rally need to exist.
You have free speech.
No you don't.
Yes you do.
You're not free of consequences from the things that you say.
You don't.
Ah,
there it is.
There one.
You can say whatever you want,
but add your right.
You respond to it,
which has now become not just responding to it.
I'm going to destroy your ability to now make a fucking living that is not tit
for tat.
That is not a debate.
There is one.
You can have a respectful debate where people feel differently about various
things.
You're allowed to protest where they tell you to protest.
Now you have to get a permit.
They made sure you're down the street and around the block and away from the
cameras doesn't freeze.
They don't rally.
Does that really make sense to you?
Is that really something that like you need to have?
We want free speech.
You have it?
Yeah.
Free speech.
You don't need a wrap?
No,
no,
no.
The order Thai would have I,
you know,
you know this,
this is like no fucking Simeon.
Mark Comedians
have gotten sued and lost in Canada.
Canada over jokes.
Yeah.
Like this is,
this is like people are in the middle.
People in the middle of standup sets in America had comedy at a,
uh,
colleges and they shut off the mic and take the mic on that they don't even
understand the fucking joke.
It's like people videotape comedians now when they tried to get the,
and all everybody's trying to do is get you in trouble.
And what that does is it instills fear and makes people feel out,
I don't want to say that,
oh,
I shouldn't say that.
Like there's people literally looking like fucking looking at the office,
even the office.
That's silly,
absurd show that everybody loved and everybody loved and,
and 10 years later,
people all,
we could never,
we could never get away with that dorky white people in the middle of fucking,
I've heard Steve Kerr Pencil.
Yeah.
Like Michael Scott couldn't exist
right now.
Couldn't exist as absurd as that guy.
I don't know if I believe that.
I mean I kind of get his point,
but like the whole,
I don't know,
the point of Michael Scott was that he was thick.
He has credibility as the man have laid that guy.
But I also,
but I also know as someone that's like my favorite show ever,
that the point of Michael Scott was that he was hilariously out of touch,
but he had a huge heart and he loved everybody.
But he always said the wrong thing just cause he was like ignorant about stuff.
But he wasn't a bad person.
You know,
he just would say dumb stuff.
And it was funny because he was so clueless.
The thing with Michael Scott was never that he was um,
mean or trying to like dig at somebody or trying to poke fun.
That identity
[inaudible] down with black people.
What's the gay lingo like?
Was trying to an unbelievable infringement on free speech since nine 11.
Okay.
Since nine 11,
there's been an unbelievable infringement.
Like you're like the way,
you're not allowed to discuss our foreign policy other than to just say the
standard,
I support the troops,
my thoughts and prayers go out to the families and the victims.
That's what you're allowed to say if you,
if it don't say that,
that don't believe in that at all.
Not that they don't support the people who are serving,
but there are very much against everything that we do in terms of wars and all
that kind of stuff.
So I don't,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't see it like that.
I don't know.
I do because I,
what I saw was if you look at the way comedians and performers active during the
Vietnam War,
they were fearless,
said whatever the fuck they wanted.
Right?
There was an,
there was an immediate,
like what the people that earn money off of war learned from Vietnam is that if
you,
if the media and the in the public turns on it,
you know,
you're,
you're going to have to leave this money making fucking war that you're in.
So what they did during it,
I don't know if it's a actual conspiracy to do it,
but what they did since Vietnam was basically all mainstream media got into the
hands of very few people.
Okay?
That's why when you watch Fox are,
you watch CNN,
there is no criticism of,
Hey,
wait a minute.
How the fuck are we going to pay?
Like now we're talking about starting a war with Iran and we're completely
fucking bankrupt.
Like how exactly are we going?
What is the end game?
Why are we doing this?
You're not allowed to ask any of that.
And if you ask any of that,
that means that you don't appreciate the truth.
They put it all on the fucking truth.
You don't like babies,
you don't think kids should have ice cream,
you're a social should get the fuck outta here.
And,
and everybody,
you know this,
this thing of like the amount of people going like,
you know,
there's no upside.
Don't say anything,
don't say,
and we've all not set anything into like trillions and trillions of dollars of
fucking debt.
And we allowed 3,500 fucking jerk offs on a jungle gym to bankrupt a first world
nation because all of us don't want to get in trouble.
And I'm not saying I don't have,
I don't have a fucking solution for any of this,
but you should be able to be like,
hey man,
just out of curiosity,
how the fuck are we gonna pay for this?
Like I understand what we were trying to achieve here,
but financially,
the way we're going about this is,
is there a better way to do this?
If you,
if you do any of that,
why don't you get the fuck out of the country,
you fucking piece of Shit socials and now in stand up,
you know,
I talked to you,
I was at the fucking danger fails and this woman in the crowd didn't like what I
was doing.
She's like,
next subject,
nobody wants to hear this.
And then at this big fucking walking out and that I think is just,
you know,
she was like young,
she was in her twenties and just grew up on social media and everybody in it,
I'm going to make a comment and everything I say and how I feel in all of my
feelings are so fucking,
it's like you,
she was talking to me like she hired me for her birthday party.
It's like,
no,
you came to the comedy club.
She doesn't get to dictate what you're talking.
And sitting there like,
like she was fucking Napoleon.
It's like I'm to talk about what he was,
fuck,
I want to talk about.
I have the microphone.
Yeah.
And she sat there and like I needed to talk about things that only she needed to
hear and then she,
I actually sat there and acted as though she spoke for everybody and I think,
I don't think it's all this big conspiracy.
I also think it has to do with how much content is out there and all of this
shit's so then what it becomes is it becomes like,
like arguing and screaming and yelling is the way to get viewers,
so that's why any little fucking dust up like three fucking jerk offs.
Having a straight pride parade gets everybody all amped up or somebody comes up
with a fucking flag and everybody fucking focuses is on that rather than,
hey man,
we're bankrupt and we're talking about starting another fucking war.
Just out of curiosity,
I think it's at what point,
at what point are we just going to go out of business over here?
I mean,
the way,
the way we're running this country right now financially is it's beyond fucking
reckless.
If anybody has as an individual ran our lives the way they're running this
country right now,
financially,
our credit cards would have been caught up fucking 30 years ago.
Well,
I didn't feel like you can have multiple things that you are concerned about.
So I don't believe in this whole like why are you concerned about this when we
should be concerned about like you can be concerned about a multitude of things.
You don't think there's priority,
but I mean there's your priorities and like my parameters might be different,
but I also feel like too,
something like,
I'm starting to think
more now,
like I think something like a straight pride parade and poking fun at identity
politics.
What the concern is that you've got people sort of stirring up this thing where
that that even though it seems so silly and ridiculous and not important,
that is informing the minds of people who feel more empowered to try to like
hurt people who identify a certain way flower.
Huh?
Who empowered them?
Feel empowered.
Who?
Who empowers those people?
Okay.
And powers.
What people,
what do you have the straight pride people?
It's three fucking people and people are screaming and yelling like it's 3
million people.
Right?
Because I think,
you know,
it's a touchy thing.
It's like this is the type of stuff where,
you know,
it's,
I feel like it's a fine line between like I should be proud to be straight and
like fuck you,
you afterward or you tranny or some kind of like other slander and that can
often lead to violence and death,
Dah,
Dah.
So that's why,
that's why it's concerning the people,
three people applying for permanent,
I just got back together and then you give them everything that they want and
then you know what,
who hears it,
those fucking people who already think those things.
But again,
as you guys are handing out flyers to now,
now I have thought,
I don't think that people should ever stop speaking up for what they believe in
and what they feel like is harmful to them and when it comes to this type of
stuff.
But again,
I harmful is a million people who wouldn't do it.
Letting know,
announcing to people who didn't even know that it fucking existed,
that it now exists,
but also I'm not going to tell people who are hurt or triggered or offended or
whatever the word is by the very idea this,
that they shouldn't be upset about that.
I'm not going to do that to them because if they are upset about it,
if this drums up feelings like,
oh my God,
this is exactly what my grandpa or my dad or whatever said that,
I'm not going to tell them then that that's why we're going to start another
fucking war and be even more bankrupt.
And again,
wait,
wait.
You can carry more weight.
It's literally like our house is on fire and you're going,
you know,
we need a new toaster.
I mean,
what are we doing here?
It's like literally we're talking about,
you know,
we're going to go under at some point we're going to go under,
I mean,
how much,
it's some fucking point.
I watched,
I watched Russia,
we all watched Russia go bankrupt.
It happens.
Okay.
I know,
but I,
I just don't think that it is your or my place to tell people what they should
be worked up about and you should be more concerned about this.
That's just my opinion,
especially when it comes to this.
I'm not very,
I've said this before,
I'm not very well versed in any of those issues.
So
[inaudible] warming will not be solved because people are going to be sitting
around talking about gender neutral bathrooms when they're going to have a place
to fucking put him is,
is like there are priorities.
Okay.
And I would say,
I mean that's like saying you don't,
do you have priorities in your personal life is just like,
well,
uh,
getting toothpaste is just as much as just as important as uh,
paying the life insurance bill this month.
No,
I don't really think you can simplify it like that.
You're such a straight pride flag.
You so black and white
because what you're arguing,
what you're arguing exists within this thing,
this large thing that's going to go under.
I,
so it's like you're,
you're,
you're on a boat that's sinking and you're talking about what color we should
paint one of the cabins rather than trying to plug up the fucking,
we're not going to have a boat.
Do you understand?
I'm trying to be as sensitive and open minded to people as I can and my own
personal,
okay.
I give up.
I absolutely,
I can't,
I,
I don't,
I give up with fucking people in like,
I just don't understand.
Like me,
I have problems,
I've got problems in my fucking life,
but nothing is more important right now to me.
Then I would say global warming and the financial fucking situation in this
country and that's fine.
Like I'm not,
because all of this shit,
all of this shit.
And how would you feel if I was like,
that's not what's important.
That's what you've been saying
as human beings,
riots and blah,
blah,
blah.
No,
I'm letting you have that thing that's important to you and not telling you.
I know,
but I'm not,
but I'm not saying what you're saying is wrong.
I'm saying what you're saying is just circle that exists in this giant circle
that's going to pop and then it's just going to be tethered to nothing.
So there's no reason to fix the fucking roof if the foundation is going to
collapse.
Like I said,
I feel like there's people who are probably more uh,
what do you call it?
I don't know what the word is better at figuring that stuff out.
I Dunno what I'm saying.
I lost my train of thought.
No,
only because what is happening is we're all screaming and yelling like they'll,
there'll be more arguments in the world in this country,
about three fucking people wanting to have a straight pride parade and versus
when was the last time you saw Twitter blow up about how much debt we're in
but also ways it gets back to the environmental thing are they're not like
hardcore environmentalist and like,
you know the Paris accord and all these things that people have been working on
about saving the invite.
It's not like it's not being tended to by people who are in charge are
knowledgeable about that stuff.
Is it not?
So is it not your responsibility to try to use less water bottles?
They're trapped,
but nobody's doing that.
Nobody's doing that note.
P Pick the same fucking people.
You'll go a gay pride parade
in the fucking thing ends and there's like a zillion fucking water bottles on
the fucking ground.
It's hilarious.
It's like there's not going to be,
there's not going to need to be any pride,
if anything,
cause we're not going to fucking be here anymore.
But if that's what you're getting from like the Gay Pride Parade,
then you've completely missed the point.
No,
I'm seeing the irony in it,
but like again,
what does that have to do with the Gay Pride Parade?
See,
you guys are sitting here and having a parade about gay rights.
I'm not saying everyone with them.
I'm,
what I'm saying is that we're just so up our own fucking ashes about,
about bathrooms and,
and,
and support the troops and fucking America and all of this shit.
We're bankrupt near,
we're fucking bankrupt.
And we're talking about starting another fucking war.
So all of this shit that we're fucking sitting here losing her fucking mind
about it doesn't exist.
It's okay if he just viewed this country is a big fucking house and were yelling
about the wallpaper in the carpeting and all that and meanwhile the fucking
thing on the other side of the house is on fire.
Although other foundations is going to collapse to sit there and say that that
you know like if we don't,
if this global warming thing,
okay he's not a fucking hoax is an absolute truth,
then all of these issues that we have are going to be non issues.
When the ocean rises up and swallows us all.
If you were a part of that community,
I think he would feel very differently but you're not so it's very easy for you
to sit back and tell people what they should and should not focus on it.
I am not
saying that you shouldn't focus on it.
You're missing my point.
My fucking point is there's not even remotely the same level of passion for how
much fucking debt we're in and what the fuck are we doing?
Maybe you just haven't found like your tribe in that or something.
Maybe you need to be on like environmental,
Twitter
when that's kind of what all they talk about.
I Dunno.
Why are you staring like that?
Cause I,
I,
I because,
yeah.
What time?
What time is it?
What's you're talking about is a subset of a subset of fucking people.
I'm saying the mainstream media,
the mainstream people who are fucking looking at memes and doing all of this
shit where the ones,
I dunno,
I give up.
I,
you know,
you know something,
I don't even know where the fuck this thing even went.
All I know is that our ability as Hugh of every different human being to live on
this planet is equally as in like just to survive is equally as important as I
don't know what
I don't know.
And I never said that those other issues were not important.
I'm just saying I just wished that there was the same level of fucking passion
existed.
Like,
like I don't understand how in 2019 I don't understand how far,
how was war legal?
We're all sitting have run around with that flat screen t cause it's saying all
this shit do if you actually looked at the fucking footage that they don't show
over here about what the fuck happens in war and you see these fucking people
who didn't do anything,
pull all their children out of rubble dead.
You know they don't,
they this the type of shit they used to show on the news.
They don't show that anymore.
They don't show it anymore.
Right.
Um,
I have to run.
Okay.
All right.
Now before you leave,
K K K K can I make a video view of throwing a water ball and haven't landing on
top?
You know,
upright moral starts screaming and that's what the fuck we'll do.
Okay.
Right.
That's great to be back.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Everybody on that note.
Well I have to,
uh,
I,
I got it.
They're going to pick me up there.
So all right,
42 minutes.
You guys got extra fucking that turned into fucking meet the press.
All right.
Listen to the music and enjoy the rest of the greatest hits podcast is Christ.
I got so fucking heated,
I forgot to read the advertisements.
You know,
you think I was,
I would be old enough to just realize when someone is just not going to agree
with me to just fucking stop.
I don't know if I'll ever fucking figure that out.
But you know what?
Me figuring that out is not more important than us fiscally and fucking
environmentally.
Everything's a priority frame.
Bridge.
Everybody father's day is around the corner and dad doesn't want another pair of
socks.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You know,
when you see mother's Day,
all this shit that they want you to buy him.
You know,
I fucking go into whole foods.
All right?
What?
They're genetically altered horse shit that they try to pass off as organic
food.
Right?
I go in there because what else am I going to go?
Huh?
There's no other fucking game in town anymore.
So I fucking go in there and they got this side advertising father's day and it
literally says,
uh,
it's a picture of a chicken Kebab and it just says,
Hey,
uh,
nothing says father's day like meat on a stick.
I go to buy your jewels and all you gotta do is get me a fucking Kebab.
Anyway.
The perfect gift is already on your phone.
Just uploaded.
Just upload your phone in order by Sunday,
June 9th,
you got water by June 9th.
But come on now.
This is your dad.
Okay.
For guaranteed free delivery in time for father's Day.
Just go to Frame bridge.com and upload your photo.
Preview your item in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free recommendations from their talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your item and deliver your finished piece straight to you or
when they can,
uh,
deliver delivered to dad in time for father's Day.
When you place your order on by Sunday,
June 9th,
I missed a word in there somewhere.
Instead of a hundreds,
you'll pay at a traditional framing store.
Their prices start at just 39 bucks.
All shipping is pretty.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first
order@framebridge.com when they use my code,
Burr B.
U.
R.
I've used these people.
Uh,
got some great frames,
photos of when I took my lovely wife who never agrees with me and my beautiful
daughter to a Europe last year and we have them right underneath the TV.
So thank you frank.
Rich,
have a great time with this.
Uh,
I stand by these guys or ladies or the days or straight pride people.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club,
dude.
It's easy to get caught up in your daily routine,
feeling like you're on the autopilot,
uh,
that sometimes if you get to take care of yourself,
well Jolly Shave club makes it easy to take care of yourself.
When that happens,
they're quality products help you look,
feel and smell your best.
You can get everything you need from dollar Shave Club,
uh,
without going to the store.
Their executive razor,
their Dr Carver's.
Easy Shave and face cleanser is the best way to refresh your morning routine.
And right now,
uh,
you can get a dollar shave club status set for just $5 off.
Okay.
It comes with all this shit I just said.
The executive razor shave butter and face cleanser.
Uh,
you're going to love it as much as I do.
Get your,
start a set for just five bucks@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burn and okay,
last but not least,
butcher box this month.
Butcher box is offering free bacon for life.
Sign up now and you'll get one package,
uh,
of the best tasting baking for Bacon free and every box for the life of your
subscription.
But your box bacon is whole 30 approved uncured nitrate and sugar free right
now.
New members will get a package of Bacon for free and every box for the life of
your subscription.
Plus you'll get $20 off your first box every month.
Butcher box delivers a hundred percent grass fed,
grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken.
And my favorite heritage breed pork and wild Alaskan salmon directly to your
door.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
humanely raised that are never fed antibiotics,
antibiotics,
or hormones.
Um,
there's no easier way to get high quality meat that you can trust.
There's no commitment.
You can cancel anytime to receive your $20 off your first box and a package of
free bacon and every box for the life of your subscription.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or renter burr at checkout.
Go now.
It's a limited time offer.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is a Monday morning podcast for
June 6th,
2011 how the hell
are you?
How was your day going?
Are you on vacation like I am?
Yes sir.
I am on vacation,
but before I get to talking about what a great fun ass fucking time I've been
having for the last few days,
uh,
I need to address the Boston Bruins for half a second.
All right.
Do you know what the Bruins need?
Okay.
They need Larry Bird or someone of his ilk.
God knows is not a lot of them to walk into that fucking locker room.
Okay?
And He needs to give that speech that he gave way back in the day when we will
get getting fucking our asses kicked by the Lakers and Larry Bird,
what's fucking went on TV or whatever.
He's getting interviewed and he's sitting there with his fucking pasty torso and
his little prepubescent and fucking mustache,
you know,
it's cleft palate,
upper lip,
whatever.
He's covering up.
I don't know,
every man's got some secrets,
but he said he sat there after getting his ass kicked by the fucking Lakers,
the Celtics.
He said,
we played like a bunch of damn sissies out there.
We played like a bunch of sissies.
He just kept saying it.
But what happened the next game?
What happens the next day?
Oh,
fucking Kurt Rambis comes down the damn court.
He gets fucking clothesline by Kevin Mchale and I believe Larry Bird.
I can't remember.
I don't have the highlight in front of me.
I'm on vacation.
I don't have time to do that shit.
And that turned the whole series around.
All right.
Now I was watching that game fucking too.
And the people commentating,
they're all great.
They're all great.
Milbury I like all those guys,
but they kept saying,
I'll tell you a Boston feds gotta be mad to what the fuck's his name?
Burroughs.
I didn't know the guy's Goddamn name.
I've never heard of him.
Didn't get suspended.
Cause in the first game he bit Patrice Bergeron finger.
Okay.
And they just kept going.
I'll tell you,
Boston fans,
it ain't gotta be upset right now.
They really got to be upset.
You know,
they gotta be upset that this guy didn't get suspended.
And you know what happens?
I guarantee you on Boston sports radio,
there's a bunch of Bruins fans go.
You know,
I'm upset because fuck face wasn't suspended.
They literally tell you what to think.
That fucking guy,
he shouldn't have got suspended.
What he did was not suspendable but was just sort of bizarre.
It was something like a six year old or rock a toddler would do.
That's why.
That's why there was no huge response after he did.
You know if your car,
you fucking slam someone face first into the boards,
you take a cheap shot.
The whole team's pile on.
He trying to kick the shit out of you,
bite somebody.
People would just stand around like,
dude,
what the fuck?
That's what Patrice version.
Woman's
doing his skate and off the ice.
He looks at a friend of visit,
the friend of his TV and he goes,
you fucking bit me.
I don't think it was suspendable.
Maybe you would make the guy wear a dress for the first period of the,
of,
of game to maybe that.
All right,
but that does not address the issues that the Bruins have right now.
The,
the fucking issue is that they're playing,
they're playing soft.
They make in Vancouver,
look like this tough physical team.
Now I totally respect Vancouver.
They're a beast of a team with gold scores.
Snipers.
Okay.
Lou Longo,
I will give,
you know,
I'll give them eight out of 10 stars because that guy can't get rattled.
All right,
but they're not a physical team.
When I looked down their bench,
there's nobody there that looks intimidating.
It's a bunch of red beer to Douche bags like me.
Every other guy in their team looks like me.
I'm not intimidating,
but the way the Bruins are playing,
I don't get it.
Chara is getting pushed all over the fucking ice.
I'm getting sick of it.
So
I'm hoping that that's what
is going on right now.
And again,
three we come out,
we stopped playing like a bunch of goddamn sissies and we hit these goals.
Scores.
That's all they are.
They're a team of goal scorers.
There's nobody tougher on their team.
Stop getting pushed around.
Did you see what happened when you check fucking what's his face there?
God Damn.
And I'm so bad with the names.
The fuck is his name.
The guy from a Lavonia,
Michigan and he used to play angry and now he doesn't get angry anymore and now
he's having a career year.
Fucking
ah,
he's not one of the said deeds,
he's fucking raw.
I can never remember names.
I'm the worst.
That fucking guy,
he got hit and all of a sudden he gets up slowly,
skates off the ice.
That's what you do.
That's what you do to gold scores.
You Slam them into the boards legally.
That's what you do.
You don't just stand there,
give up the Blue Line.
Oh Wow.
Look at them.
They're so good at pathing.
I'm getting sick of it.
All right.
You're making the will make Vancouver look like they're the fucking fliers.
They're not.
All right.
This is exactly what we did against Montreal.
We made Kerry price look like the second coming of fucking Patrick Walk Cause we
kept taking slap shots from the fucking red line with nobody in front,
right in his goddamn pancreas.
Another save by Carey price.
I'll tell you the pro,
it's gotta be buckled little shut up.
And where do we do?
We went down out to,
do we have it in us again?
I don't fucking know.
I don't,
but I would like if we would actually return a couple of checks every once in
awhile.
They've actually been too great fucking games and I'd be way more excited about
it if,
uh,
if we weren't down [inaudible] you know,
all these fucking Douche conduct fans who haven't said Shit to me all year.
My Twitter's blowing up after they win games,
by the way.
No,
no shit.
Talk before the game,
you know.
Then they give me a bunch of Shit,
you know,
walking around with their chest puffed out because they want to one to nothing
game.
It's fucking annoying.
Then they've given me shit cause I'm not texting during the finals.
I'm sorry,
my team hasn't been there in 20 years.
I don't want to come up with clever shit during the fucking game.
All right.
Okay.
Enough of that shit.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm on a vacation and a,
you know a lot of people when they go on vacation,
Nia,
could you not put away the plates so loudly please?
I don't know if you guys can hear that.
That's very disturbing.
I'm taking,
I'm taping the podcast right now.
Hey,
how nice is it to be in like a house?
Huh?
It's very nice.
Thank you.
You know what?
Sometimes I call her over and she wants to talk.
Other times she doesn't,
I think she's annoyed with me.
Even on vacation,
I can only get like six hours sleep because halfway through like the night,
all of a sudden my brain's like,
how come you didn't sign up for crab soccer in seventh grade?
And then I got to walk around and think about that shit.
Uh,
what's crab?
Soccer,
I don't know.
Vacation in New England.
Someone will explain it to you.
Um,
just reminded me of a fucked up story.
We used to have this gym coach.
This guy was the shit and you know,
he drank a little bit
and he gambled a little bit and it was the 80s.
So you didn't really hide it.
He come in with this red nose and I remember we would play,
it was fucking awesome.
We would play
football and we had gym class on Mondays,
so there was always Monday night football.
So basically what he would do,
whoever's playing Monday night football,
let's say it was the Brown's verse,
the Lions,
He'd divide up the gym class and he'd go,
you guys are the browns and you guys are the alliance and whoever wins,
I'm going to bet this on the game.
And he'd flashed this big wad of cash and we thought he was filthy,
stinking rich.
So anyways,
we'll play and crabs saga.
And uh,
this kid scores a goal,
right?
And this guy used to like the guy was the shit he used to like announce the
games as you applying them.
He'd be like,
Oh shit.
Look at Barrack Day fans.
He's all over the place and it just gets you amped up.
The Guy was the greatest gym teacher slash human beings
ever.
So anyways,
this kid scores a goal.
All right,
Danny scores another goal and he's like,
he's flipping out all the shit and then he yells,
if you score another goal,
I'm gonna buy you on a tare.
Which in our world is seventh graders costs like nine zillion dollars.
So needless to say that the kids' scores,
the fucking goal,
and he starts flipping out because the gym coach is just hyping him up.
Just kept screaming over and over again,
I'm going to buy,
you want to tare?
I've got a buy.
You want Atari and we're all going nuts.
He's going to buy him an Atari
next week.
Hey duty by the Atari?
Nah,
no,
not yet.
Not yet.
But he's a week after that he ever gets you to get down a tire and I hadn't
gotten to me.
Yeah,
he never got it for,
you know,
typical gambler is all great.
It's all great.
He builds you all up and then right when you need them,
a fucking walks away from you.
But the Best God damn gym coach I ever had,
um,
was that even remotely interesting?
Well,
you know what,
I don't give a shit cause I'm on vacation.
Technically.
I'm not even supposed to be doing this.
I'm supposed to be on vacation.
What'd you guys do?
You called me back to the office.
Now I'm shuffling around looking for those papers.
I forgot my wife and kids are out in the car.
I swear to God he just can't leave his job for more than three days.
Um,
anyways,
you probably wondering where I'm at.
I'm actually at a,
I dunno,
I travel all the fucking time.
Okay.
I travel all the time and I'm always going to airports and you guys know how I
feel about that.
And I always get on a plane and I'm always sitting next to some fatty.
Right.
And they always look at me a little,
you'll make at least smaller every year.
No,
no sir.
No.
Well maybe a little bit,
but in general you keep getting fatter
and I know it's a disease.
Okay.
Anyways.
Yeah,
there's always some fatty spilling into my goddamn seat.
Okay.
Or I get the island in the,
some fucking Douche with a weak bladder.
And every time I start to nod off with my heavy head and it starts to find,
you know,
I just start nodding off in is my heavy heads going forward.
I started having dreams about being slapped in the back of the neck.
Oh,
that's how I should have done that joke.
And I didn't realize it's actually just the weight of my head.
See what I did.
I front end loaded that one with the punchline.
Do you guys just learned a little something for all you people who send me
emails about how to do stand up comedy?
Here's rule number one.
Don't put the punchline before the setup.
Oh Geez.
Um,
anyways,
so I decided I don't want to go to the Goddamn airport,
but I'd like to get away from my apartment.
So after years of living out here and everybody telling me how great big bear,
um,
mountain or big bear summit or big bear fucking polo grounds in lake,
whatever the fuck you call this place,
um,
I decided to come up here,
rented a little fucking cabin slash house and I feel like I'm in New Hampshire
right now.
It's awesome.
It's fucking cold out.
The water is freezing.
I went on a hike yesterday.
I felt like I was going to get hypothermia.
This ladies and gentlemen is the vacation of a redhead,
you know,
and fellow red heads out there.
Freckled face fuckers Ginger's whatever the hell you want to call us.
Stop trying to be like regular people.
You know,
everybody wants to go someplace warm,
right?
They go down in the Caribbean and then you show up just blistering in the
goddamn son.
Why are you doing that to yourself?
You know,
and then people just sitting there going,
you,
yeah,
that's them.
You can't get any color at all?
No.
I mean I'm like white,
but you're just wow,
look at your legs.
I'm sorry.
That was just,
he just standing there like a fucking freak.
Don't do that to yourself.
That's not the vacation of redhead.
Redhead goes from mild climate too.
Severely cold climate.
That's,
that's how I feel.
My next vacation is going to be in the Yukon territories,
you know,
and I'm going to get some snow shoes and get one of those Eskimo jackets.
All right.
And I'm going to walk across the Tundra,
my little red nose.
So anyways,
we're up here and a big bear fucking lake.
And I decided I want to go.
I wanted to go on this hike two days ago.
And uh,
you know,
Nias the exact opposite of me.
She can sleep until the cows come home.
She's a relaxed,
beautiful person.
I am a psychopath who's totally wound up.
So I'm up at like five in the morning and I want to go on a hike.
She doesn't want to go.
So I say,
fuck it.
I'm going right.
It was more like nine in the morning,
right?
Which is five in the morning when you're on vacation.
So I walked into the Goddamn Woods and uh,
this isn't like hiking in La.
This is the real deal.
Like they have bears,
they have mountain lions and a,
and I'm by myself and I wasn't really thinking,
I go hiking in La by myself all the fucking time.
So I wasn't thinking about anything.
But I got to tell you,
the second I got into the forest,
this isn't the woods,
this is the forest.
This overwhelming feeling of being watched
just fucking came over me.
You know,
this is what it's like walking in a forest.
Okay?
If first you recognize the animals,
when you first get in,
you're like,
oh yeah,
look at,
look at the pile.
And Ah,
that's a squirrel.
Hey,
look,
a little chipmunk,
right?
Then you get about a quarter mile in,
and then that's the first time you see something move.
You're like,
dude,
what the fuck was that?
Is that a dog?
A little bit,
a little dog with a fat tail.
And then you get this failing you like,
wow,
that thing was running around like it's nervous.
That means somebody,
yet something else is bigger than eats that.
And then there's something bigger than that that eats that.
And you know the deal.
And I started hearing Bill Curtis,
his voice in my head,
you know,
his girlfriend didn't get up,
so he decided to go hiking alone around seven 30 that evening when bill didn't,
Nia started getting worried
and that's where they use horrific words like remains,
you know,
they find my torn jacket,
one of my legs just laying on the fucking path.
That's when I started.
So I overrode my ego
and I said,
fuck this.
And I turned back around and I immediately was like,
I'm going to get a knife.
I,
if I'm going to go on here by myself,
I at least need a knife.
I'm going to get one of those big fucking Daniel Boone stab a grizzly bear right
in the fucking throat.
Right?
So I go to the fish and tackle place down there or whatever the hell it is,
the sporting good place.
And I say,
yeah listen,
I'm going on a hike.
I want a knife just getting freaked out.
Then I'm going to get eaten by a mountain lion.
And the guy's like,
Nah,
you don't want a knife.
You don't want to get in.
Do you want a knife to get,
you're going to,
you got to get in close with the knife.
And I was thinking about that.
How hard a grizzly bear cans,
you know that by an bitch slap that they have.
Will Your fucking head spins around you break your neck.
Just imagine me still being able to hold onto the knife.
You know the average NFL running back,
if he gets stuck by Ray Lewis fumbles the football,
I'm going to be able to hang onto this knife.
Taken a fucking bitch slap from a grizzly bear.
It's gonna fall on the ground and that's going to rip my face off.
And then I'm going to be on Oprah talking about how I feel blessed that it rip
my face off.
Cause now I know what's important in life,
right?
Isn't what,
isn't that what they always do after somebody gets their face ripped off or they
get burnt to a crisp and then they just sit there,
Yay.
Realize what's important in life is actually the best thing that ever happened
to me.
I took everything for granted.
It's just like,
whoa.
It's amazing that,
that,
that's how they feel.
Because I would not feel that way.
I would fucking be like,
Nah,
I would be lying to everybody in the hospital that I felt great and I felt
blessed and I would then climb onto the top of the hospital and I would just
roll off.
Yeah.
What I'm saying people I would not do well with that challenge.
You know,
the,
all the religious people say that,
that the Lord only challenges those,
that he feels are strong enough.
I'll tell you right now,
that's why I still have a face because he knows I'm a big fag.
Um,
anyways,
so the guy goes,
listen,
you don't,
you don't want a knife.
What you want is some pepper spray.
I go,
pepper spray.
He goes,
no.
this is,
this is like bear pepper spray and I'm looking,
I got the package right here.
It says Grizzly,
tough pepper spray,
and there's a picture of a bear counter assault bear deterrent c.
So they're already given in what this product that you're going to get
assaulted.
It's not assault preventer,
it's counter assault.
Because basically the Goddamn bear is going to be coming at you so fast,
you know,
and those things can't stop on a dime.
They're like a giant SUV.
They're going to,
you're going to hit him with that fucking pepper spray and it's going to do a
barrel roll right over you.
And they feel lucky.
It's going to keep fucking going.
So anyways,
he says this shit is actually strong enough to blind a fucking human being,
but evidently not a bear,
which doesn't make sense to me because like I said,
as much as I can understand that a bear can bitch slapped me down off a fucking
mountain,
you know,
and eyeballs and eyeball,
right?
You poke a bear in the eye,
he's going to do that little fucking,
you know,
that little dance,
you know the,
I got poked in the eye dance.
Even a bear's going to do that.
So anyway,
so I got this shit cost me 50 bucks,
right?
So I got this shit and then I went on a hike yesterday with Nia.
Um,
up to,
what was it?
Bertha summit.
Bertha peak.
Leah.
Yeah.
Bertha peak,
which was like a two and a half hour goddamn hike.
At least for us.
I know some Douche from big bear's going to write it and do,
actually I can do it in 45 minutes.
Can,
yeah.
Well go ahead.
They're fucking Tonto.
Have a good time.
Um,
so I buy this shit right?
And what do I do?
I forget it like an asshole.
So then I just,
you know,
I said [inaudible] fuck it.
There's two of us,
you know,
he is a lot more curvier than I am.
She probably looked like a better cut of meat.
I'll be fine.
What?
Come here,
India,
come over here.
Let's talk about the hike real quick and then I'll dismiss you coming into the
studio.
Dude,
I'll tell you,
this is how much this is how much of a of a,
of a fucking red head I am is that not only do I want to come up here to this
freezing cold lake,
we actually have a Jacuzzi here on I and Nia convinced me to get into this shit,
uh,
two nights ago and even that was too hot for me.
It wasn't even that hot.
Oh,
I can't handle that.
I can't fucking breathe.
I can't,
I hate that.
I hate her.
I ain't having a hot shower.
I hate all that.
I hate the sun.
I don't like heat in general.
I like being up here where it's fucking cold.
Okay.
I like how you just said that like,
like I'm acting like you were challenging me.
It's okay.
It's okay to like cold things.
You know what I don't like about this place?
I don't like how every cabin you ever rent has like,
it's like whenever you go into the bathroom,
there's no heat whatsoever.
You know?
Now that I've bitched about how I like,
you know,
hate the heat,
but I don't like that.
You go in there,
right to relieve yourself and you're like your shirt.
Your shirt is blowing in the breeze and every one of these fucking cabins.
It's always like a story.
Dude.
My grandfather built it back in the twenties this even a cabin.
What is it?
This is a full on house.
This is a house.
No,
it isn't.
Look,
it's got wood on the ceilings.
It's got a moose head above us.
This is a cabin.
It's got a sled hanging from the ceiling.
It's got two fireplaces.
Yeah,
within sight of each other.
This is a cabin,
but it's a house.
It's on ground.
There's a backyard.
Look,
I'm not saying there's dirt floors in the remains of Abe Lincoln in the corner.
All right,
but if we went to look at this God damn thing,
would you call this thing a house?
Like if people are looking for a house,
would you be like a seasonal?
I like a cabin.
I see what you're saying,
but
oh Jesus.
Trying to get a woman to agree with you.
If you want to hear something that this guy wrote in,
this guy wrote it in,
wrote in all the way from Afghanistan.
Let me see if I can find this here.
Is overrated.
Underrated.
This is a classic here,
right?
Overrated.
All right brother.
I got one for you.
Overrated.
Trying to have a logical argument with a woman you're dating that.
Just wait.
Do I need to be here for this?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because you need to balance it out so this doesn't come off as totally massage.
Monistic all right.
What?
You don't have to be here.
No,
go ahead.
All right.
Just come on here.
Beef.
Be Fun.
Have Fun.
All right.
Overrated.
Try to have a logical argument with a woman you're dating.
It never ceases to amaze me every time I overhear some retard complaining about
some chick that won't listen and won't listen to them and argues with them all
the time.
Any veteran dude who's been with the check over 48 hours knows that they don't
stay on topic and they don't think logically they aren't trying to fix shit.
It's an emotional thing with them.
So why anyone thinks they can talk to a chicken?
That mindset is beyond me.
The way I see it.
Most guys go one of two routes when presented with an angry bitch.
This guy seems enlightened,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Why should I listen to anything in this fucking apple has to say,
don't let them make you mad.
He's throwing you off your game anyways.
Either they choose the path of least resistance saying yeah.
Over and over again and nodding and gazing into oblivion.
Lot of guys do that.
Those are the hen peck guys.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay,
fine.
Yeah.
Yup.
Um,
cause they know whatever they say won't make a difference or they pander to
their petty weak emotions and sensitivities by talking slowly,
uh,
at adult whisper trying to come and appease them.
Both methods have their benefits.
However,
I'd like to offer a third avenue if I may.
I've been faithfully married seven years now and it works so far.
Not that I'm an expert,
but here you go.
Here's his,
his third one.
All right.
First,
like any competitive dude,
you beat them at their own game.
When they come at you saying something like,
why is this stock on the ground?
And I told you to put it,
blah,
blah blah.
And that Bitchy,
whiny.
I wanna fight voice wagging their finger and cocking their head sideways with
this guy on a reality show.
Or is this I was wife reacts.
Um,
anyways,
you just reply in your loudest tone,
whatever the fuck the last thing that pissed you off was.
Um,
and as you say it,
you keep eye contact and walk straight up to them.
So basically if you said,
why is it,
why are these socks on the ground?
I'm supposed to in my loudest voice,
go and not break it.
Contact,
walk right up to you and be like,
what did you do
and not,
and he's not done yet.
This is the beginning.
This is the first quarter.
Okay,
let's let the game plan unfold here.
Um,
all right,
what the hell am I lost my place?
Uh,
usually this will startle them,
um,
as they come back.
No,
come on here.
You've got to listen to as they come back.
Can you tie this is like they tell you what to do when approaching a bear or
something like that.
Okay.
Make a lot of noise.
Just let me finish Douche bag.
Let me finish.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm here.
I'll be all right as they come back with what?
Uh,
as they come back with,
what does that have to do with whatever we're arguing about?
You just pulled down your pants and start jacking your dick while they stand
there with that dumb,
confused look on their face and C'mon,
you gotta be back here for the reactions.
All right,
so
and while they try and know,
this is obviously Joe,
okay,
maybe this is forward thinking.
Let me,
let me finish here.
This is a new strategy and while they try to regain whatever thought they had in
that scanner breaks skill,
you just keep going to town,
not saying a word.
If they talk to you till completion,
you just say thank you.
That's about what that argument was worth.
And you walk away as you leave,
pick up the sock or whatever and tossed it in the hamper.
There you go.
That's,
that's his thing.
Well at least he still puts it away.
Yeah.
Yes.
Everybody's happy
now.
He's joking.
Obviously somebody who's pandering to your over the top completely ridiculous
misogynistic statements now today on a weekly basis on this fucking podcast
trying to impress you by coming up with,
I've seen this time.
It's one or two.
Wait a minute,
let me just wait a sec.
No,
this is just some copycat fan.
I'm supposed to take this seriously.
Like this is a real thing.
I don't,
I'm not giving this thought next.
Anyways,
so he said,
Bill,
you're way with dealing with women is pretty good,
but it's passive aggressive.
I don't even know what he's talking about.
And I know how you feel about that shit about being passive aggressive.
Uh,
even if you're doing it to maintain the high road for your future breakup,
why does it matter if the re what does it matter if the relationship is over?
I don't know what he thinks my strategy is.
Anyways,
he said,
you might as well say fuck it and go out in a blaze of glory.
Granted,
I know about losing your cool and shit like that,
but in the end it just builds up and leads to a bigger blow up.
You end up,
uh,
staring at the ceiling or yelling as you drive in the car thinking,
damn,
I should've come back with this or that.
No,
fuck that.
Uh,
no matter how,
where do your snap your comeback is,
it wouldn't have made any difference cause that bitch isn't going to listen.
The only thing you wouldn't know that this guy's happily married.
The only thing you don't sound happily married letting it,
you're letting this guy get to you.
He's totally winning right now.
You're getting mad.
He said to pull out his dick and jacket until completion.
This is bullshit.
Why am I listening to this?
Just trying to be funny.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what,
and you know,
what you're doing is you're being a fun sponge.
You just soak it all the fucking,
that totally isn't really taking it seriously.
Like that lady on NPR lady who I talked to the other day to hype this Gig,
and I was talking about Arnold Schwartzenegger and she just goes,
I don't think that situation is funny at all.
So of course that really,
that doesn't think it's funny at all.
Well,
it doesn't divert me.
So I just plow into my fucking material and it's just dead silence.
And the other two comics are laughing.
So she goes,
I don't find that funny at all.
I go,
well,
you know,
I always all my jokes,
I usually end up losing half the,
I mean,
wait a minute.
She goes,
I always,
I always end up losing half the crowd.
And this is the NPR egg head response.
She goes,
actually,
I'm a third of the crowd.
But it was,
I was hyping a better fit.
Yeah.
So I didn't say anything.
I want him to be like,
oh to share.
She did the math,
she ended the interview when we,
when we ended the interview,
she goes,
okay.
And that's,
I'm so and so and this has been how to build a birdhouse with the special comedy
addition,
whatever the stupid NPR story was.
And then she,
and she goes,
okay guys,
thanks a lot.
She goes,
yeah,
that wasn't as funny as I thought it was going to be.
She actually said that to us.
Yeah,
totally cool.
I'm being the NPR lady right now.
Yeah.
Cause you're actually thinking that this guy is going to like is happily married
for seven years and he goes up and he screams in his wife's face while like
she's a grizzly bear and then takes his dick out in Jackson occasionally to
completion.
See,
you know what it is?
What is what it really is,
is that I annoy the shit out of you and I,
my views about women are so fucking annoying to you that the second this guy
started talking,
you were,
you weren't yelling at him.
You were yelling at me.
I'll fucking yell at you too.
So get it off your chest.
Um,
I'll tell you what's on my chest.
What is your problem?
You want this great guy,
all tired,
fucking rented out a cabin by the lake to house.
It's a house.
I'll go with that.
Really?
What the Shag rugs do you tell them how amazing our meal was last night start?
No,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't get off topic here.
Oh,
I want to know what is your goddamn problem with me?
Nothing.
I just want to sleep longer.
You come in there and you're like,
Ooh,
what's going on?
So your fucking nose and my ear.
I want to sleep well because it's the Monday morning podcast.
I have to do it Monday morning or else the title doesn't make any sense.
My Monday morning listeners,
by the way,
not yours.
You're selfish.
Cons my morning.
Go ahead.
So that's what I was saying.
I know you want it to be on the podcast.
So I was saying,
you know it's going to get a little loud out there.
Yeah.
All right,
fine.
Yeah,
yeah.
One of these days,
the day you realize that you don't have a leg to stand on in this relationship,
we're going to get along so much better.
That doesn't make any sense.
Yeah,
it does.
How great was the cowboy steak house down the street.
Oh,
delicious.
Yeah.
Huh?
The fucking ribs.
Yeah.
I'm going to hype it.
You know what?
I don't have any advertising this week,
but I'm going to fucking hate this place.
It's called the cabinet.
A cowboy steak house.
The cowboys take us on a,
I forget the street.
I don't know what the fuck is his big bear lake.
Yeah.
Big Bear.
Like you can't miss it.
It's one of the three restaurants up here.
So we come walking in right immediately.
You know.
You know they got like the country music just to get,
oh boy.
Never meaning no harm but laid above the blue.
They got all this country,
fucking songs played.
So Nia obviously gets nervous,
right?
Places like that.
Yeah.
I get a little concerned that you get nervous.
You know it's going to be like rude and everyone's going to stop and look at me.
What in tarnation she doing in here?
Yeah.
Even though we're in,
we're in California.
Yeah.
But,
no,
but no,
but that's the thing though is the second you get outside the cities is it gets
a very,
it can get very Macon,
Georgia quickly.
And sometimes it doesn't like up here.
It doesn't.
These people are all cool.
Thanks everybody is very cool.
But we went in there and you were like,
you were asking me if you thought,
you know,
if this second I smelled that food,
I was like,
this,
this is going to be good.
That was delicious.
Yeah.
I saw that big fat guy eating the ribs.
I was like,
this is how fat was that guy.
He was pretty fan.
He had a whole thing to himself.
We split it.
He's had those guys.
He's one of those guys who's so fatty.
Wears shorts all year round
pans or to castrate.
Dude,
I don't get cold.
Why wouldn't you?
You're fucking Walrus.
What gets you your biggest prop,
Mike?
That's easy.
Only gap here and get attacked by a polar bear.
Thank you.
All right,
so anyways,
so this guy actually asked me what my strategy is with women.
Well,
I'm going to tell you this,
I actually a,
I'm doing a giant chunk of material on this.
Um,
I disagree with you.
Women argue,
stay on topic if they're right.
All right.
If they're wrong,
that's when they do all the diversionary tactics and they try to make it about
something else.
And if you're not going for it,
if you don't fall for their diversionary tactics,
then their last ditch effort is trying to just to try to make you mad.
Like what you did to me yesterday when he kept saying I was acting like a baby.
Cause you knew I was right.
You're right.
It's like you're acting like a baby.
I said once he said it more than once.
No,
I did not know.
Then you came in the bedroom and you said,
why are you acting like a bay?
You're throwing a temper tantrum.
Slammed the door.
I walked away.
Calm and cool.
Then why did I hear the door close?
Because it's a fucking solid object.
It because it's a door.
Doors make noise when you open and close.
I didn't slam it.
Wow.
What happened is slamming the door now.
I didn't send the door.
I didn't slam the door.
And you said that's not okay.
That wouldn't work in a debating class.
We're not in a debating class.
We're on your,
on my podcast.
A podcast.
All right.
You know what?
You don't have to be here.
I don't.
I don't need to take that on my vacation.
How fucked up was that hike we went on yesterday?
We went,
thank God that hike was your exit.
Yeah.
And you know what?
You are great for the first 90% that last 10% I don't want to go.
And you started doing that toddler thing where you make in your arms go limp and
your head was going back.
I was,
I was frustrated.
I hadn't met.
Yeah,
it was a long,
tiring,
difficult hike.
Beautiful.
But you know,
and you know what?
I realized there three hours,
whatever,
in a plan crash and we survived.
I'm going to have to be the guy that makes something happen.
What are you talking about?
I'm talking about that last 10% of the hike when you tapped out,
you're tapped out.
Yeah,
but I kept going.
I just kept quiet.
Why?
Cause I kept urging you on like a fucking team leader.
Wow.
I didn't expect to go on some like ridiculous hike.
I told you we should do like a little moderate.
There was nothing particularly about it.
Oh please.
My feet were killing me by the end of it.
Yeah.
I wear those.
You watch a middle,
a middle aged white guys wear the new,
the gray new balance with the inserts and we had to get you one of those.
What are those things that people put on their foot and they look like the foot
and it's supposed to be really good for your yeah.
What are those sneakers but their feet fuck things creepy.
You live there.
I was going to say a primate.
We're all fucking premise.
But you look like a fucking ape.
Yeah.
All you need is your big toe to be bad.
And some of you with hammertoes gets one of those on,
on a reverse hammertoes with a fucking the big toe sticking out.
They're gonna look like a goddamn chimp.
Anyways,
let me plow ahead with the podcast.
All right,
cause your exit done.
I just heard them eggs and making bacon.
All right.
I know I'm arguing for arguments.
Yeah.
He argued for it and I'm saying all right,
all right,
I'll see you.
I'll see you on the other side of the cabin.
See that people,
that's how you handle them right there.
Ready to say walking away.
You Talk Shit about.
So getting back to that guy,
um,
my strategy yet is you don't,
you don't lose your cool.
You stay on target,
right?
Like that dude and star wars.
You stay on target and um,
when they're saying over the top mean Shit,
you don't respond to it because that's just them.
Um,
you ever see a goat get choked to death by a python?
Anybody else?
Watch those fucked up youtube videos.
You know this stunned at first they fight and then there's that middle part
like,
dude,
what the fuck?
What is this?
And then the very end when they only have a little bit of air left,
they fucking kicking their legs like a maniac before they die.
That's the female version.
That's the goat version,
getting getting killed by a python Jesus Christ of,
of women.
When they start saying that means shit,
that's that last little kick of the legs before it's over.
So I don't respond to that shit anymore.
Actually,
I do a little bit,
but I've got myself to the point where I know that it's happening.
And then that's what I did yesterday.
She started doing that shit and I just took my plate of food and I walked in the
other room and,
uh,
I'm telling you,
but the big thing is,
is if you're wrong,
you have to admit it because that gives you credibility in the future.
So there you go,
sir.
And that was an absolutely fucking hilarious email and it made it even funnier
with Nia sitting here taking it seriously.
That's ridiculous.
He would,
he wouldn't do that.
I don't,
I'm calling bullshit.
He didn't jerk off till he came
like his wife.
I got it.
Tell you though,
uh,
that would be,
that would be fucking hilarious to do that.
I mean,
I could stand there and rub my dick,
but it would just be so funny to me.
I don't think I could get a hard on.
I gotta be honest with you.
Oh,
that's disgusting.
All right.
I have a dentist.
I've been going off on the French lightly,
so some,
uh,
American born person who,
went over to France,
which I don't know if I'm buying,
I think they just want to hear my opinions on what French people are really
like,
you know,
and I'm from America,
so you can trust me like that shit I always talk about on the,
uh,
whenever there's some sort of political debate.
The Obama is a moron and I'm a democrat.
All right,
here we go.
Hello Mr. Berger.
I enjoy your podcast very much and I'm also a fan of your standup power.
Um,
I don't mind you poking fun at the French people too much.
I don't give a fuck with your mind and not you condescending comment.
Um,
even though I am French,
I just wanted to inform you about the stereotypes.
That's funny.
How come you don't inform me about other stereotypes that I do on this podcast?
Oh,
because it came around to you.
Now you give a shit.
Okay.
Mainly the stereotypes about the French are assholes who hate America.
Um,
okay.
Okay.
And this person's gonna debunk all these.
Or give me more information.
All right.
Number one,
Europeans generally hate Americans because,
and I was born and raised here so I can say this Ma'am or mister,
whoever wrote this shit,
you could say it anyways.
All right.
Stop trying to get some sort of credibility by saying you're from here.
I don't give a fuck where you're from.
All I know is you live in France,
so you've got information and just,
just give it to me.
All right.
Europeans generally hate Americans because Americans go to different countries
and behave rudely.
Uh,
they expect things to be like in the US,
such as portion size and the ability for everyone to speak English.
Whenever I go to France and see American tourists,
I get so embarrassed because they are noxious and expect everyone to suck their
superior American cock.
All right,
let's stop right there.
First of all,
when Europeans come to America,
you guys act like assholes too.
Yeah.
And Nia just goes and you don't tip.
You don't give a fuck about our customs with tipping.
You don't fucking tip.
And then all you do is you come to America and you trash it.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I,
when I go to other countries,
I'm not a rude prick and I would never go to another country and then tell
people who live there,
why their country sucks.
That's what Europeans do.
Okay.
And you kind of beat me to the punch here where you say,
cause they expect everyone to suck this superior American cock.
I was going to say,
wow,
you sound a little insecure.
And she says,
or he says,
Europeans also have inferiority issues.
Another reason they don't like Americans.
I don't know how many times I've been told by Swedes,
uh,
the English Germans and so on that America sucks.
And is making the world a worse place.
This makes me extremely patriotic and wanting to defend the u s but I digress
from the French dude.
I actually feel these.
I got agree with you on that one.
That makes me want to defend it.
And it's really funny if the English or the Germans
ever talk about a country making the world a worse place.
Okay.
Cause you guys passed the baton to us.
We're standing on the shoulders of your work of evil.
Um,
Swedes,
I don't know anything about you.
You weren't in any of my American history classes.
The only first sweet I saw him was on the muppet show.
Remember that?
Borghi Borghi Org ed board.
Orgeave,
Orgeave keyboard.
Bork Bork Bork.
Here we hear you hear me?
Should he be?
Um,
but I addressed with Fred's number two a,
the French are not assholes per regions are assholes.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I wasn't born yesterday.
Really?
You have all your assholes quarantine just in Paris.
There's not one asshole up near the beaches of Normandy.
Huh?
Or down in Nice.
You're telling me I go to Cannes film festival.
There's not going to be some local asshole.
There is going to be a cunt.
The French Riviera.
C'Mon.
Okay.
Evidently Nia,
all the asshole French people are just in Paris.
Um,
so Mary,
many Americans go to France and only stay in Paris and then assume that all of
France is like Paris.
This is so ignorant.
Um,
it infuriates me.
well,
you know,
it's the fucking jewel of your country.
Those are the smartest people you got.
And when they're rude comments,
they are urine.
Basadur who goes to fucking Paris to go to see a farm?
I mean,
goes to France to go see a farmhouse in the middle of nowhere.
Let me ask you this,
sir.
Or ma'am,
if you weren't lived in France and you came to America,
where would you go?
Would you go to Nebraska?
God knows you wouldn't find any intelligence out there.
Fuck you buddy.
You tried growing some corn.
Um,
that is like a,
going to New York city and assuming that all Americans are like New Yorkers.
Paris is like New York full of unfriendly people who want you to get out of
their way.
Big cities are like that.
Small towns are populated by nicer people.
Uh,
a trait common in all countries.
Well,
I'll definitely say they're much polite or I will agree with that in smaller
towns,
but they also tend to be a little more fearful and a lot more racist and a lot
more easier to sway into putting Saran wrap around their outhouse because they
believe that they're going to be the next victims of a terrorist attack.
Like logically that works in their mind that the terrorist attacks going to be
World Trade Center,
one to the Pentagon and then you're out house in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Like that's the next logical military strategic target.
Jesus Christ.
Is this podcast even funny anymore?
Sometimes.
Sometimes I just lose myself in the sentences are number three French women
shave the only woman in France who don't shave or the elderly,
Middle Eastern immigrants.
Last time I went to France,
I told my aunts that Americans don't think they shave and they were very upset
by this.
When I went to camp,
all the girls shaved at the beach and went to the beach.
They were all shaved.
In fact,
the French say Scandinavians don't shave.
See stereotypes about people in different lands exist everywhere.
Wow.
I think I learned something.
Um,
why the need to put down the women of foreign countries?
Because it's funny because that's what guys do.
We break balls and we say,
your women are ugly.
They're hairy,
their vaginas are horizontal and they're not good leis and we got bigger dicks
than we can fuck them better.
It's basic shit.
Talk Page one chapter one of talking shit about another country.
And um,
I dunno,
I find that all of this to be very condescending.
You know,
as you're sitting there saying stereotypes exist everywhere.
And I love how the French are getting offended by what we think of them.
While they think we're all illiterate,
fat fuck's going to a,
to a Carl's Jr.
I mean,
it goes both ways.
And I'll tell you why we think that French women don't shave is because there
was a pop song over here a long time ago,
a long time ago called 99 red balloons.
No,
I do not own red balloons,
blah,
blah.
Babba,
Bam,
Bam.
Yeah,
that's shit.
Right?
And in the end of the video,
she puts her arms up and add a Harry fucking armpit.
And that was it.
And she was from Germany,
but it didn't matter to us all know European women shaved.
That was at,
it was over.
And plus when you look at your continent in,
realize that it's basically,
for the most part,
the meat of it all right?
The countries that we give a shit about is actually smaller than our entire
country.
Like your countries.
So the size of states over there.
So we figure if they're not shave and in Germany,
why wouldn't,
why would they shave and fucking,
uh,
France?
I mean,
if people in Massachusetts are drunk morons,
do you think that in Rhode Island they're reading?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Does that make any sense?
I just feel like I'm coming off dumber and dumber with each fucking podcast and
a,
you know what?
There's something freeing about it.
A number four older Frenchmen smells.
Not all the French back in the day.
And I mean way back,
people didn't wear deodorant.
My grandmother does.
And all the other women.
You know what I'm realizing,
I think a lot of the French stereotypes came,
came around our World War One and World War II.
Uh,
you guys haven't needed us to come over there and fight a fucking battle.
I'm joking.
I understand that world war two was our pay payback for a you guys helping us
out in the revolutionary way or understand that right?
Most it,
the revolutionary war,
the French and Indian war.
I can't fucking remember.
I have no idea.
I don't even remember anymore.
They just all,
I hated that part of history.
Any sort of powdered wigs,
anything pre cowboys and Indians I just could give a fuck about.
And even then,
that was very sketchy.
I liked reading about the younger brothers,
Jessie and frank.
James Cole younger.
I like reading about that shit.
Um,
and I liked reading about adventures at sea,
you know,
pirate ships in that type of stuff,
but anything with powdered wigs are those American presidents with the big bushy
beards and no mustaches.
It absolutely put me to sleep,
so I can't remember.
Um,
so there's a stereotype for you.
Not only do we not know about other countries,
we don't even know about our,
um,
uh,
number five French girls are slutty.
Well,
I'll give you that one.
But the French on a whole artist puritanical as Americans.
Um,
yeah,
we're just all into getting STDs.
Um,
and see sex as a private means of pleasure.
That one shouldn't be too ashamed of.
I think it's healthier than keep your legs closed because sex is evil.
You whore view.
Um,
I definitely think,
yeah,
we take it too far in this country.
But uh,
last I saw the first AIDS patient caught it in France.
Oh,
I pulled that one out of my ass.
No Pun intended.
Right.
Nia is looking at me that,
that's not true.
The first guy who got it was that was over in France was a flight attendant
patient number one.
Ground Zero isn't that right now?
Oh Jesus.
You know something.
Someday when I run for office,
I think that's the one that's going to come back to haunt me
anyways.
You know,
I was just fucking with you.
They have Frenchie or former American person,
whatever.
Um,
yeah,
I don't give a shit.
What am I dreams is to go to Paris and I think that's going to be happening
later on this year.
Why you ask?
Well,
I'll tell you why.
If you go to billboard.com you'll notice that all of a sudden Mr Fancy pants
here has a uh,
a run of dates throughout Scandinavia and a in October.
Go to [inaudible] dot com be,
you are our go to the left hand in the left hand corner.
You'll see all my dates and scroll down to October.
I am doing a Helsinki Oslow Copenhagen and Stockholm,
Sweden,
so I always get confused.
Oslow is Finland,
Helsinki is Norway,
Stockholm,
Sweden.
I've been that.
Copenhagen,
Denmark.
How fucking awesome is that.
So I'm tossing a one night in London before that.
And at the end of that,
I think I'm going to go to Paris.
Why the fuck not right?
That is if the American dollar doesn't collapse in August and we're all in
worker camps.
Speaking of that Shit,
have you guys seen this stuff about the uh,
oh,
the suicides at the,
uh,
the apple plant,
you know,
that really cunty commercial where they go,
uh,
you know,
if you don't have an iPhone then you don't have the iPhone.
You know,
and I wanted to get an iPhone until I saw those goddamn commercials and they
kept like,
uh,
just,
it's the most bizarre advertising.
It makes me angry at the IFA.
I never had any anger towards the iPhone or the people who had one.
I never gave a shit.
I was like,
I phones to shit.
I heard it.
It drops calls.
I'll wait till it's on Verizon.
And then right when it gets on Verizon and I'm all ready to jump on board,
they come up with this Nananana fucking cunty shit going.
You know,
if you had an iPhone right now,
you could be looking at the inside he a fucking throat and uh,
diagnosing your fucking throat cancer before it even happens.
You know?
But if you don't have the iPhone,
you don't have the iPhone.
It's like,
well fuck you on cute and sticking with the droid.
So anyways,
now I read they just had the 10th suicide
at the apple plant.
Now who's kitten heel?
We all know that everything that we're wearing,
everything that we're using is made by some four year old making 6 cents an hour
somewhere we'll ever deadly.
They,
these people have had enough.
They've had 10 suicides at the apple plant.
Here we go.
On the same day that apple,
Dell,
Hewlett Packard promised to look working conditions at China's Foxconn plant,
a 10th worker committed suicide.
The death of a 19 year old male male worker.
Uh,
it's too bad.
He was like one year away from getting his fucking severance pay or is ah,
shit,
I fucked it up.
What the hell do you get it when you do 20 years on the force?
Ah,
I'm sorry everybody.
I'm on my fucking vacation mode.
What the Hell I get my pension.
What does that,
when you work 20 years on the force
and he's only 19,
you get it.
Cause he's been working since he was two.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
the death of a 19 year old male worker also came just after the company's
billionaire founder took the media on tour of the sprawling complex in response
to accusations from Labor groups that workers toiled and sweatshop like
conditions.
Oh,
hilarious.
So then the billionaire shows up,
they cleaned the place up,
stick in a water bubbler and go say,
it's great.
Um,
and I know what a lot of you fucking heartless [inaudible] gonna say,
you're gonna say,
well,
sweatshop labor is necessary.
Do you want to pay $8,000 for a laptop where here's my rebuttal.
You know what if the content that top didn't have to make $1 billion a year,
you know,
kind of like when they were talking to the oil companies and they go,
you're projected to make 350 billion.
How about you just make 340 billion?
Do you have to make that much money?
That's the thing.
The people at the top are taken way too much fucking money.
There's no fucking way that the only,
a reasonable way to make a laptop is to give people such shitty wages that
suicide is a better fucking option.
And you do it at the fucking plant to make some sort of political statement.
There's just no fucking way.
How about the people at the top?
You mean
once you got $100 million to over what,
what do you do you ever need to get another paycheck?
I don't understand that.
And I'm not saying that the people at the top shouldn't be filthy,
stinking rich because they came up with it.
But you shouldn't be paying people.
This shouldn't be sweatshops,
everybody.
That's all I'm saying.
And what sucks is that we actually came up with unions in this country because
of sweatshop like conditions.
And uh,
but what ended up happening was the people in the unions took advantage of it.
And with their strength,
they became a bunch of slothy Douche bags to the point that there's a lot of
people who actually have negative views about unions.
That's how bad it is in this country.
And they're actually excited that they're going to do away with unions.
A lot of people want to do away with fucking unions rather than reform them.
But to do away with them is we're going to end up like these poor bastards in
fucking China,
you know,
so and shit together and go and you know what?
I think I'd rather out of fucking window then make another God damn iPhone.
Um,
so anyways,
it says the company is bought psychiatrist and Buddhist monks to the factory,
to the factory complex to support workers and now plans now play soothing music
along production lines.
Why don't you just fucking pay them?
Okay.
Um,
it plans to install 10 foot tall,
tall fences to stop workers jumping from buildings and may give workers a 20%
pay raise.
This is how tight these fucking rich cuts are.
Let's play soothing music and put a fence up.
We'll try.
We'll try that first rather than just giving them more money.
What is it?
What is it 20% pay raise when you make an 8 cents an hour?
Um,
and anyways,
Foxconn representatives maintained that the increase would not be in response to
the suicides,
but is being considered because business has been good.
Give me a fucking break.
Did you hear that?
Near the 10th suicide at one of those apple plants,
the sweatshops that killed themselves over there,
so they decided to put up a 10 foot wall so they can't jump and they're playing
soothing music and they're considering giving them a 20% pay raise.
Ah,
there you go.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
Let's,
uh,
let's move on here.
A lot of interesting,
a great emails.
By the way,
this week people sent me some really interesting stuff here.
Um,
and shit that I can actually help people out on here.
if I could just get to the goddamn thing,
people put your feet up.
Here's a little fucking commercial here.
Um,
God damn you.
You fucking whore.
Where the hell is it?
I,
you know,
some days I just really fucking hate myself and this is one of these fucking
moments.
This guy sent me this great email asking if maybe it was under advice.
Here it is.
This was a professional podcast.
I would have fucking edited this part out.
All right,
advice bill.
Uh,
this is going to sound a little gay,
but I'm gay,
so fuck you.
One of the great sentences ever written on this podcast.
All right.
I'm a 2128 year old guy who's hair is thinning.
Oh,
geesh.
Um,
I always told myself that I wouldn't be one of those guys who was obsessed over
this and I just shave it off when it comes to it.
Um,
but in recent years I've gotten lots of compliments on my hair and I don't
really ever hear any compliments about anything else regarding my appearance or
my amazing personality.
I kind of hate to be just another dude with a shaved head walking around getting
fatter.
Uh,
I'm considering taking medication for hair growth.
But the side effects include everything.
Impotence to making the early stages of prostate cancer to masking the early
stages of prostate cancer.
Should it develop?
What would you do?
Do you risk impotence and potential cancer in order to keep the only thing about
yourself that receives compliments from others?
Um,
I've noticed you've shaved your head in the past,
but well,
I don't want to look like that.
Nah,
I'm just fucking with you.
Uh,
hey,
maybe I should just work out and get ripped then it wouldn't matter.
Right.
Well,
the thing about going to the gym is fuck that thoughts.
All right.
Well,
coming from another balding fucking mail,
um,
I said the exact same things you said.
I wear my s hey,
you know,
when I used to watch those commercials and then watching these people dumping
shit on their head,
they'd be like,
Dude,
you shave your fucking head.
People make funny for a week.
And then they used to it and then they eventually see pictures with you with
hair and they go,
dude,
you look weird with hair.
I like it better without it.
And then I started losing my hair and I freaked the fuck out.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
Um,
you know,
I was like,
I was like that guy in the full 48 hours.
Gans when he finally gets shot,
I got shot.
I can't believe I got hit.
I remember that I was that guy.
Um,
so I went out and I got the Rogaine in that shit.
I dumped that shit on my head and I felt my heart rate increase.
It has different effects on other people.
I know another guy took it.
He said,
dude,
I was taking a piss and chunks of something was in my urine.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I couldn't do it.
I did,
I think I did it full a couple of months and one point he just saw myself in the
mirror dumping that shit on my head.
I was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Fuck this.
You know,
I can't do this shit.
So I said,
fuck it.
And I stopped using it and uh,
and then I just shaved my head and I said,
fuck it.
And,
uh,
and I got to admit,
I haven't,
a shaved head is fucking awesome.
But what ended up happening was I booked that movie date night.
They go,
we want you to grow your hair out a little bit.
So I grew it out.
Um,
and then I started booking other shit.
By the way,
what I booked,
I,
I've been joking around,
I got to set the record straight here cause people are really starting to
believe that I'm on glee.
Yeah.
I got to tell them because they're like,
people are like twittering,
then I'm on glee and they're gonna miss the show.
I'm actually,
I'm not on glee.
I actually,
I booked a of two episodes of my favorite show on fucking TV,
uh,
breaking bad.
And,
uh,
the only reason why I said that was because they're super top secret about their
scripts.
They don't want anybody to know anything.
And I wasn't even sure if it was okay to say you even booked a roll on it.
I didn't know.
I didn't know if they were that top secret about it.
So I just started joking around saying I was on glee.
And,
um,
then I did the show a couple of times and ask them.
They're like,
no,
it's fine.
But I was so far down the road with that lie.
So I just kept saying,
so I am not on glee and shame on you.
People actually believed that I was flying to New Mexico to do an episode of
Glee and that we were doing the peewee Herman Mexican hat
dance.
Really?
You really fell for that one.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah.
So,
uh,
so I grew my hair back out and,
and um,
but I'm still not using anything and I'm starting to get the friar tuck thing in
the back of my head.
And,
um,
but you know,
once you shave your head,
you don't give a shit about going bald.
You just kind of keep it short.
And,
uh,
I,
if I was you fucking gay,
dude,
I,
you gotta do it.
Shave your head because you're trying to attract other guys.
And guys were superficial assholes and we were 100% about looks.
I think if you shave your head that says a lot about you,
you got confidence,
you're not trying to hide anything.
And you deal with,
uh,
you deal with,
with the shit in your life.
You don't try to hide it and stick some magic goop on top of your head.
Not to mention,
I think they're going to cure it one day.
You know,
when,
when I'm in my eighties and urine,
like your seventies Isam,
shit,
they're going to cure.
It
will just pop a pill,
you know,
don't have a full head of jet black fucking hair,
and we won't have the fucking ass cancer,
right?
So that's what I would say,
Shavia head,
right?
And Go to the gym and get shredded.
All right.
And as far as your attitude towards the gym,
if you don't want to go to the gym and you just going to become a fat fuck,
ah,
it's not going to matter.
I don't even think you're going to live long enough to even go bald.
All right?
So go to the,
shave your head,
go to the fucking gym.
I'm telling you,
having a shaved head is the shit and uh,
I,
I really want to fucking do it again
and I will in the future at some point.
I'm just going to be when I have to nature's gradually doing it for me.
So Dude,
you should try it.
You never had a shape that it's
fucking awesome.
It's awesome.
You just wake up,
you're ready to go.
You fucking ready to go.
And A and who gives a fuck?
Right?
Think about it.
Don't you think if you are going to be Brad Pitt and would've happened by now,
what are you really worried about?
Are you worried that your ranking on the world,
people magazine's 50 most beautiful people is now in jeopardy that you're not
going to make it?
Have you ever made it before?
You know,
actually,
I shouldn't make these jokes that you,
cause you kind of seem like you have low self esteem.
All right?
You know what your problem is,
dude,
I think that you're a little shy and you sitting around eating cupcakes and a
feather in your fucking hair.
All right?
You need to start eating more protein.
And some vegetables,
go to the fucking gym and shaved your head.
Bam.
Gavel hits a fucking next case.
Next case.
That's it.
It's over.
All right.
Moving on.
Oh,
I asked people last week about a coaching,
talking about crazy,
uh,
stories with coaches,
that type of thing.
And,
uh,
I had a crazy coach and I can't even fucking tell you this shit this guy did
just because,
uh,
people I know from my childhood listened to this thing,
so I really have to fucking watch it sometimes.
So,
um,
all right,
here's some,
here's one.
I don't know.
I don't know what I did with the email.
I'm going to paraphrase.
I just remember this guy said he,
uh,
he was playing on a baseball team.
He was like in the fifth grade I think.
And um,
he was the kid who played right field,
he wasn't good or whatever.
So they're,
they're playing the game that's before the game,
that's before the game for the championship.
So I guess they're in the fucking semis and there's a guy on second and let down
by a run and they getting down to the final inning and he's coming up to bat and
he sucks.
So He's already nervous.
And he said his coach went up,
grabbed him by the arm and looked him in the face and said,
hey,
if you don't get a hit,
I'm going to punch you right in the face.
And he said at first he laughed because he thought the coach was joking,
trying to break the tension.
And then he realized that the dude was serious and he just sort of walked up to
the plate and he was standing up,
they're shitting his pants and he looked back at his coach and his coach is
staring right at him.
I'm like,
I'm going to punch you in the fucking face if you don't get a fucking hit.
So this kid throws the bad out there and he somehow slaps a fucking Derek Jeters
opposite field,
single drives in the run.
Instead at the end of the inning,
he went back to the bench.
He said,
the coach never said anything to him,
never address it again.
And he says he's hated that son of a bitch from uh,
to this day.
So he said,
his question was,
what is this guy?
Is he a,
is he a good motivator or z or horrific human being?
I mean,
this is the thing.
It's because you got a hit.
I think,
um,
that's a weird one that,
that one is that guy is both right and wrong.
He's wrong for taking the game so seriously.
And I'm injecting that sort of reality into your childhood,
which I think kids should get a dose of reality in their childhood,
but I think it should come from the parents,
or at least the parents should be supporting another adult.
Like say you fuck up in school when your parents go there.
Old School parents would go to school and whatever the teacher said you were
doing,
the parent would then look at,
look at the kid and be like,
yeah,
why the fuck are you doing that?
Um,
but something like this,
I dunno,
he did motivate you.
He did let you know what the real world is like.
He basically gave you an a nutshell.
Yeah.
In life.
You know,
when,
when society needs you to produce,
if you don't produce,
it kicks you in the balls and you,
you,
you don't get the position.
You don't get,
you don't get a fucking race or whatever the fuck it is.
I'm trying to say I got damn and I can't talk this fucking week.
You know what I'm saying?
Here's another story from
coaching a bill loved the podcast,
but,
uh,
I am co I'm a coach.
Uh,
I coach a team ages nine to 10 and I'm the assistant for Aau travel team.
Is that ninth to 10th grade that traveling?
There's gotta be that the travel teams coach or my son around my nine 10 team,
that's gotta be nine to 10 years old and they travel at a Vietnamese.
I didn't know they let American kids do that.
Both are very good players and are two of the four best players on my team.
I have three slots for the all star team.
Oh,
Jesus.
Oh God.
So you're the coach,
you got two kids on your team and there are two out of the four best players on
my team,
I have three slots for the all star team.
All right,
so two slots are taken and now it's down to my son and the travels coach's son.
Yeah.
Well why did you give away those first two slots
with I guess if those kids were better than than your son and your buddy's kid.
Um,
okay.
So his son is hitting 600 place,
third,
third base,
shortstop,
and second and his pitch five good innings in six games.
He is only field it about six balls,
but that's not his fault.
Um,
my son is hitting six 12.
Hey,
you know what?
The podcast listeners,
I want you guys to vote for this.
Like this is the MLB.
All right?
So the first guy's kids hitting 600 he's play third,
short and second.
He's pitched five good endings in six games and he's field and only about six
balls.
But that's not his fault cause he can't control who hits it to him.
I'm,
his son is hitting six 12 has caught every,
is caught every inning except the three innings he pitched.
He's thrown out eight people in six games.
And in four of the five games we won,
the other team's catchers sucked.
And we just stole our way around the bases.
Even without pass balls.
Uh,
we have not,
we have not had an a player thrown out stealing.
Well,
this has to do with the rest of your team.
The game.
We lost their pitchers shut us down in short,
in the six games,
he is hands down the best patch catcher.
I've seen the travel coach.
His son has a little higher level fielding,
but I feel my son had a bigger impact on our team.
Uh,
batting is a push.
Oh,
because he's 686 two.
who do I pick for the all star team?
Ah,
fuck.
All right dude,
if you weren't related to your kid,
you gotta,
you gotta uh,
you got to pick your kid.
He's,
um,
he's batting 12 points higher and he's gunning down the other team's runners,
you know,
so after the pitcher fucks up,
he's correcting pitchers fuck up while not fucking up himself and hitting six,
12.
But it's your son,
God,
Jesus.
Well,
I mean,
you can give it to your son.
I think he's worthy of it,
but you know,
you're going to jeopardize the,
uh,
your friendship with the other person if you're fine with that,
I give it to your kid.
Um,
but you know,
if you want to teach your kid a little bit of something about being humble and
about handling a position of power properly,
I'd give it to the friend.
I think that that's what I do.
But I would sit down and I would,
I would have a talk with your son and try to explain that the position of power
that you're in and how it would look.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
This sounds like a Mcdonald's commercial,
doesn't it?
Back in the day when they'd sing some sad song and the kid wouldn't get it at
first,
then you buy and some French fries in a fucking vanilla shake.
You know,
it's times like these,
I'm glad I'm not a parent dude.
Wow.
That's a,
that's a,
uh,
that's a tough one.
That is a tough one.
All right,
well I've got time for one last one here.
Um,
hey bill.
I'm a 27 year old graphic web designer and I've been unemployed for a few months
now.
The job I had a few months back was a web development job at a company I thought
was awesome before I worked there,
but turned out to be real,
a really shady place that had a really bad history,
uh,
of having um,
high turnover with their employees.
In any case,
I've been living back with my parents now for two years because I lost the job
back then and it just,
enough money saved up to live out the 13 month lease that I had signed on my
previous apartment.
Ever since I've been struggling to find work.
Like,
I'm sure a lot of people are,
however,
almost all of my friends have jobs or been able to find jobs fairly easy easily
when they didn't have one.
I attribute this mainly to the fact that they are most,
that they mostly have jobs,
not careers.
Like I've been trying to build over the last half a decade or so,
but with it being so hard to find a job,
I'm wondering if I should take up a new career.
I love graphic and web design and uh,
and I'm damn good at it too.
Uh,
I've even been looking for jobs out in California area because Florida sucks and
I'm not a fan of a hundred degree weather with tons of humidity,
but it's,
it's been more difficult to find work out there because most places won't even
consider me since I'm not living out the yet,
I have no money to just up and move without any concrete employer employment on
the line.
What should I do?
All right.
Yeah,
Dude,
you're getting your stories right now.
Every successful man has his stories about sleeping on a Futon,
eating fucking Eggo waffles.
Those are the years you're in.
So what I would do is I would get a job,
get a fucking job.
Anything you got to do,
get a fucking job,
get some money coming in and then save up your money.
Okay.
During the day,
that's your day job.
Just like I had,
I had a day job working in a warehouse and the nights I did comedy for free.
At night,
you come home,
you do your graphic designing for free.
Okay.
Get a job where you meet other people.
Maybe the company needs some sort of graphic designing.
You can offer up your services,
you know,
and then you can add that to your resume and then there's other people maybe
have side businesses.
I'd get a business card.
I put that up all around town,
cheap graphic designing.
Just happy to be here.
Graphic and web designing.
That's what I would do.
I'd get that business going and while I kept working my day job and eventually
you will have enough fucking money or your,
your graphic design,
we'll be making enough fucking money where you can either move out to California
or fuck California,
run your own God damn business.
All right.
I'd say what's your problem is
here's your be in too damn picky.
All right,
you got to do whatever you gotta do.
Fake it till you make it right now.
And uh,
I'm basing that on the fact that you've stuck with looking for a career rather
than a job.
That's a good thing.
Sometimes I can shoot you in the foot.
And also how you want to leave Florida because you don't like the weather.
All right?
Right now is not the time to be a diva.
Deal with the fucking humidity.
Bust your fucking ass.
All right?
Don't get into a relationship with some woman.
You don't need it right now.
What you need to do is to rub one out in the morning.
Go to that fucking job.
No.
And as you're at the job,
try to network with people.
If you're fucking you,
I'm just gonna say everything that I just said.
Just do all that shit.
Bust your fucking ass and you'll get there and you have all these great stories.
All right?
Then you get a good look and broad at the end of it because God knows they like
money.
All right.
That's the,
that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Uh,
I've got another couple of days up here.
I'm gonna enjoy my fucking vacation,
going to go jet ski and I'm going to have some stories about that.
And,
uh,
I'm gonna bring my bear mace on another hike today.
Hope you guys all have a good week and a,
let's go,
Bro.
It's,
I'm looking for them to turn it around.
No disrespect to the Vancouver Canucks.
I got a beast of a fucking team.
I just don't think there's anybody tough on your team,
which is a evident when you're going around biting people's fingers,
like fucking a goddamn toddler who just got his fucking toy taken away from him.
All right,
that's a podcast for this week.
I'll talk to you later.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Awesome.
[inaudible].